yeah and then I didn't really have any
other funny insane stories other than
the time that I went to the gym with
Aaron and [ __ ] died nearly that was
funny oh yes and you uh threw up yeah so
so I don't know what it is
um I I I can so I obviously I have
exercise a fair amount yeah but
obviously on the tour ride next size in
like three weeks right and um I have
this thing that I don't know when to
stop
when my my body is telling me to stop
I'm like yeah but that's just that's
just that's just like baby [ __ ] I'll
just keep running yeah and then I always
regret it because I realize I've ran
past a certain point of like no return
where my body will now not feel good and
I will actually have like [ __ ] my body
up right right so
I I we started uh Aaron was like let's
go to the gym I really want to go to the
gym and I okay so how this all came
about is the night before I was like
yeah let's go gym Aaron but we were kind
of having like a few drinks and stuff
and I woke up the next day and I didn't
really want to go to the gym anymore and
so I showered and I came out of this
room and in the corner Aaron was just
sitting there on the couch and he's like
so you've shout huh
not going to the gym anymore and I was
like no no I'm still going I just want
to shout out for the gym
trying to freshen up a little bit you
know you know what's what assuming all
right let's go to the gym right now
begrudgingly getting my stuff out of the
bus to go to the gym so you go to the we
got like the Gold's Gym and Aaron's like
what do you want to do and I was like
well I normally do cardio then I
normally do like muscle exercises and
he's like yeah sure whatever so I think
he was like all right let's do cardio
but let's do it how I used to do it when
I was prepping for Creator Clash yeah
okay so we're doing basically boxing uh
yeah and this [ __ ] I knew it was going
to be brutal but I was like well I can't
be a little I mean I just like I did my
first one of my first few times hanging
out there yeah I don't want to like let
him down and obviously I I my cardio
exercise is definitely different from
this he wanted to do a like a 15 20
incline at our like a six miles per hour
Pace uh which isn't crazy but it's
pretty tough God if you haven't done it
and you haven't been practicing this
type of workout that's tough yeah so
we're running this for about uh I want
to say about five minutes and I'm I'm
struggling and he's like all right we
can stop and I'm like [ __ ] okay good
good he's like we'll do one more round
after this I'm like okay [ __ ] I will do
one more round [ __ ] [ __ ] I normally do
cardio and I probably go like you know
I'll do like around like 3K nothing
crazy just kind of like get the cardio
burn a few calories right yeah I get get
the fitness just there and then I'll go
on to wait and spend more time doing
that
so this is just like I am not prepared
for this
so we start doing the other one and
about halfway through this like five
minute incline thing I can feel my body
being at the point where it's like you
gotta stop or we are going to have
consequences yeah yeah but I'm like no
no we'll keep going we'll keep going so
keep going for some reason I can I can
keep going even when my body's begging
me not to and I don't know why I've
always had this problem from a kid where
I like whatever my internal limit is I'm
just like no no it's fine and I keep
pushing myself it might never matter
yeah yeah this used to happen a lot in
like races where in school if we were
doing like a big race for like the end
of year race thing I would do the whole
race and right at the end I would just
throw up yeah because I would just keep
going right yeah and this happened a few
times and I haven't done it in a few
years
um it's normally when I haven't trained
enough yeah so I go and I do it and I
feel awful and so we start doing some
weights and I do one we do a whole set
of like chests it's fine but something
feel a bit more rough
come on I can keep this down I can keep
this down I'm not going to throw up I
just felt queasy and I didn't feel good
and we started doing uh triceps and I
just I hit this wall where I was like I
don't feel good so I go I'm like Aaron
I'm gonna go to this world real quick
and so I just sit in the toilet you know
you sit in the toilet for five minutes
yeah like Shinji like yeah yeah just
collecting your thoughts yeah I'm like
I'm just trying not to throw up yeah and
so I'm like okay I think I got to the
point where I don't feel great but I
think I can continue yeah
so I really wanted to continue the
workout because we you know we were like
I was having bonding yeah yeah I was
having a good time and he's he's super
[ __ ] nice right yeah you know Aaron
if you watch this you're such a [ __ ]
nice guy and I just thought I just
wanted to not be a weirdo what's a trash
day so I I you know then we go back and
I do just one more like rep yeah and
then I was like tell her I'm like Aaron
yeah I'm gonna I don't feel so good I'm
gonna go to the toilet real quick and I
go and I just I'm just like it's like
[ __ ] Team America on this toilet for
a good three four minutes I'm trying to
rinse my mouth toothpaste so my mouth
feels gross but I'm like rinsing my
mouth out I'm like oh God and I'm like
and I'm like I feel much better now like
dude I feel you know when you throw up
and you feel way better but obviously
like your stomach still hurts from
throwing up yeah right but I felt fine
like I felt good to go because mad
training yeah so we continued the
workout so normally the way I do it and
it's this is just a me thing I know
there's whatever way you want to do it
normally what I'll do is I'll do cardio
and then I'll do four sets you know um
so four four different workouts and I'll
do 10 10 sets two sets of 10 reps four
sets is that how it is
um that's how I normally do it and then
so we finish these four and then he's
like all right time to do core workouts
and I'm like oh no I don't think he
realized I threw up I I thought I made
it clear that I did but I don't think he
realized he's just like breathing his
face no no no no no so so luckily it
didn't smell too bad because I I could
feel it in your mouth you feel like it's
staying here it wasn't too bad luckily I
don't know wow and so we're doing core
it was just stomach right and so so
we're doing these workouts and I'm like
ah and he's like damn you get that burn
going I'm like this is another bird I
wanted [ __ ] so are you supposed to feel
it from the inside yeah
I somehow get through this court I am
[ __ ] actually I came back to you guys
and I was like
thank you
Aaron didn't realize I'd thrown out but
I told the other guys that yeah I just
[ __ ] threw up felt awful yeah and
then afterwards he's like you threw up
that's awesome
he said I didn't know that yeah I was
like y'all saw him I was like I thought
he just took a [ __ ] man I thought he
took a [ __ ] and just felt better that's
when men workout
myself out at least I'm happy I got a
workout done I I try my best to do some
workouts and the Tour Total I only got
two workouts done over yeah two like a
month and a half but but yeah but you
know what is impressive about that and
and the entire tour for that matter is
that we all found out not too long ago
somehow God forbid maybe some divine
intervention came in we all lost weight
yeah I was I don't know how for sure I
call it the hamburger diet you know I
would say it's a new diet it's like a
keto get the [ __ ] out of here I ate
everything on the food chart yeah yeah I
had like a family pack of Doritos every
night yeah every night oh because like
every place we'd go to right ever I
swear to God every [ __ ] place so we
tried to like go to as many like local
chains local try all the local foods
every like American food is either
burgers or meats or meat and cheese or
fried stuff yeah there's there's nothing
that's hot dogs pizzas hot dogs just
like the the most unhealthy food you can
imagine and at the beginning I was like
yeah I'm let's let's do this I'm
traveling around America let's try all
the local [ __ ] dishes for sure by the
like end of the tour when when we'd like
talk to like the fans and they'd be like
yo have you tried this burger joint I'm
like I'm getting to the point where
[ __ ] all Burgers taste the same now
I'm like please do not recommend me a
burger joint right now I will literally
throw up okay [ __ ] man I had so many hot
dogs as well I was trying to try every
like local hot dog style yeah yeah and
some of them are god tier dude yeah I
like the Chicago Detroit and uh DC hot
dogs it's so good yeah but I will say
yeah at least there's a lot of overrated
things I think the most overrated thing
in America is chicken waffles I think
it's so overrated it's not that good
yeah I mean like we I had chicken and
waffles a couple of times um we had it
in North Carolina North Carolina I had
it in Mississippi as well I I had
chicken and waffle and my body has never
been more oh bro it felt like I was
dying it was it was like sensory over I
was just like am I having breakfast
lunch or dessert I'm so like my body is
yes my body was just like what is going
why why you have why am I having
breakfast lunch and dessert at the same
time this is not a taste profile I am
like I I will like it all I don't know
yeah I love chicken tenders what what is
chicken waffles it's uh exactly exactly
what you think it is a waffle with
chicken Fried Chicken Fried Chicken
Fried Chicken on top of the waffles with
cereal with syrup oh my God yeah yes
like soccer stations
take the chicken not the one it's yeah
it was insane and like you know it's
cool as like a novelty thing right being
like you know this is something that is
like very American and whatever and the
first time I had it I was like okay yeah
this is actually kind of bomb you know
it's pretty good but holy [ __ ] I feel
like I just put on like 17 pounds